refuser la cruauté du monde le temps
d'aimer est venu sur l'édition du rocher
et on va s'attarder d'abord sur le titre
avec cette phrase qui est presque
christique le temps d'aimer est venu
vous trouvez qu'on manque d'amour
aujourd'hui
si je me suis l'idée de ce livre est
dépendant le confinement on a tous
tellement souffert de cet effondrement
des tendresse et d'ailleurs je commence
ce livre par les visites que je faisais
à ma maman en EHPAD juste avant le
confinement et donc quand le confinement
est arrivé et que j'ai vu les gens
tellement souffrir de ne pas pouvoir
aller voir leurs anciens j'ai partagé
cette douleur en fait et aux deux
extrémités finalement les deux parties
de la population les plus vulnérables
faire les anciens et puis les très
jeunes et les ados qui ont été enfermés
où les étudiants qui ont été enfermés et
après cette cette période d'effondrement
des tendresse et quand j'ai vu la
politique les décisions politiques aussi
cruelle aussi brutale je me suis dit
mais j'ai donné 30 ans de ma vie à la
politique et je vois comment les choses
sont gérées et ensuite dans la parole du
désespoir des gens et cette parole elle
a pas été prise en compte et donc ce
livre c'est aussi un peu leur donner la
parole par rapport aux souffrances qui
qui ont eu lieu
aussi un discours optimiste pour dire
maintenant il y a la politique en fait
aussi autre chose et ça peut faire
confiance aussi faire confiance aux gens
pour qu'il intelligence collective
croyez encore il y a beaucoup de
Français on en reparlera tout à l'heure
qui qui me disent moi Cyril on n'y croit
plus on croit plus on la politique on a
voilà on est on
croit plus en rien voilà on préférait
limite voilà que tout repart à zéro
qu'on soit dans le chaos parce que quoi
qu'il arrive on a voté à droite ça s'est
mal passé à gauche aussi au milieu aussi
donc aujourd'hui on n'y croit plus vous
croyez-vous encore ce que vous vous y
croyez il faut y croire parce que sinon
il y a plus de il y a plus de démocratie
il y a plus d'espoir et quand on voit
aujourd'hui certains jeunes dire mais à
quoi bon donner naissance à des enfants
dans le monde tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
avec la crise climatique avec cet
effondrement de la politique moi ça me
fait mal au cœur parce que si on échoue
à transmettre ce cette envie de
transmettre à nouveau la vie on échou
sur surtout et donc je pense oui qu'il y
a d'autres choses d'autres façons de
faire alors d'où ce d'où ce livre vous
savez le grand historien Marc blog
disait notre peuple mérite d'être mis
dans la confidence
il mérite d'être
actuellement est-ce qu'on les écoute
assez on en a parlé tous les deux
Ségolène Royal noir parlera tout à
l'heure parce que c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire juste pour
prendre exemple moi on a toujours dit
aux Français si vous travaillez si vous
avez un travail si vous travaillez tous
les jours de 9h à 19h et ben vous allez
pouvoir vous en sortir aujourd'hui
problème qu'on est en France c'est qu'il
y a de plus en plus de Français qui
travaillent tous les jours et ce qui
s'en sortent pas et qui s'en sortent pas
très vite dans le mois notamment à cause
de l'inflation donc là
osé pris il y a quand même d'autres
façons de faire d'autres pays ont réussi
par exemple à baisser la TVA
c'est-à-dire l'écoute qu'on doit
apporter à ceux qui n'arrivent plus à
appeler les fins de moi malgré leur
travail il faut il faut apporter des
réponses à cela et les réponses elles
sont elles sont réalisables si on
considère parce qu'il y a deux façons de
d'exercer le pouvoir soit aimer le
pouvoir pour le pouvoir soit aimer les
gens qui vous ont donné le pouvoir avec
la préoccupation permanente de leur
faire du bien et pas de rester à
arc-bouté sur des décisions parce qu'on
les a annoncé ou parce qu'on les a
prises on sait qu'un homme politique il
peut dire je me suis trompé voilà un
président ou un Premier ministre qui
peut dire je me suis trompé je crois que
j'ai fait une erreur je vais parler aux
Français je vais leur dire que j'ai fini
erreur voilà j'avoue je vais revenir en
arrière ce que vous l'auriez fait vous
si vous aviez été bien sûr
exactement
en discutant avec les Français
avec les les camionneurs en particulier
les camélias m'ont dit non on va bloquer
on va bloquer la France on a acheté les
barbecues et les brochettes etc et quand
ils m'ont dit on a acheté les barbecues
et les brochettes j'ai regardé j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient raison dans le dans
l'objection contre le contre les kotax
parce qu'on voyait les transporteurs de
chou-fleur de Bretagne qui payaient plus
plus cher que les grands transporteurs
internationaux qui prenaient l'essence
en Belgique qui traversait la France je
prends des licence en Espagne donc il
essaie donc vous êtes revenus en arrière
et donc j'ai arrêté et quand les gilets
jaunes ont commencé j'ai appelé Emmanuel
Macron ah oui j'ai rarement je le fais
mais là je l'ai fait parce que je me
suis dit mais c'est exactement la
répétition de la crise sociale
précédente il faut arrêter tout de suite
il faut d'abord arrêter tout de suite il
y a cette souffrance pendant pendant des
mois de tous les côtés d'ailleurs donc
je pense que le comme je le dis dans le
livre ce que je décortique 30 ans de vie
politique le mot montrer comment il y a
des dérapages exactement dans l'exercice
du pouvoir et comment on peut faire
autrement c'est le mot amour et si tu es
178 fois dans le livre Daniel ça vous
fait rêver non non mais c'est vrai et je
vais vous dire le début du livre il est
très émouvant
parler comme nous l'avait dit un instant
de votre maman t'en EHPAD du grand âge
de la dépendance et très vite vous
faites le lien avec le confinement et
ses conséquences vous dites peu de temps
après que ma mère s'en fût aller
encore un pays majeur on est un pays
majeur mais on est traité comme des
mineurs on est traité comme des comme
des enfants qui ont fait peur pour
qu'ils obéissent ça c'est très nocif
j'ai presque quand les gens ont peur
ils perdent de leur énergie ils perdent
de leur capacité d'invention ils perdent
de leur capacité de résistance c'est
comme quand on élève un enfant si on lui
fait peur ou si on lui dit demain sera
pire qu'aujourd'hui mais on lui fait
peur il peut pas grandir sereinement un
peuple une société c'est pareil si on
l'encourage pas si on lui dit pas bah il
y a un horizon il y a un objectif commun
on va équilibrer les choses on va
participer sur le sur la façon de faire
et sur la façon de procéder à ce moment
là on peut grandir collectivement vous
dites dans le livre une phrase qui est
très forte avec sans doute ce triste
calcul prévoyons et annonçons le pire
même mensonger pour avoir ensuite la
reconnaissance du pire qui n'arrive pas
ça c'est une attaque
je rends public la circulaire sur les
menaces de coupure de courant
la France c'était est-elle devenue aussi
bas que on nous annonce des coupures de
courant même sur les respirateurs
artificiels vous vous souvenez de ça et
en fait c'était faux il y a pas de
possibilité de couper le courant
puisqu'on ne peut pas couper le courant
dans les zones interconnectées où il y a
des sites majeurs par exemple comme les
hôpitaux comme les comme les lieux de
survie donc c'est impossible on pouvait
pas couper c'est faux et en plus il y a
un potentiel de production suffisant et
je raconte quand j'étais mise de
l'énergie tous les ans le directeur
d'EDF venait me voir en dire il faut
peut-être annoncer des coupures de
courant puis ouvrir les Sandra à charbon
justement dis mais non vous êtes payés
pour pour délivrer le courant
l'électricité si vous si vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire ça vous quittez votre
poste et je nomme quelqu'un d'autre et
jamais j'ai justement vous avez été
ministre de l'Énergie justement c'est en
ce moment là on voit là on voit plein de
boulanger de de de petits magasins de de
gens qui sont obligés de fermer parce
qu'ils ont des factures d'électricité
qui font que ils ne peuvent pas tenir
est-ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui vous
connaissez bien le sujet ce qu'il y a
des solutions pour ces Français qui ont
vu leur voilà leur facture d'électricité
multipliées par 10 et vous imaginez bien
à boulanger quand il est à 1000 euros et
que c'est pas moi ça devient 10000 euros
il peut pas ils peuvent les baguettes
ils le vendent ils les vont toujours le
même prix donc est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des solutions ou parce que
on en parle pas assez mais chaque jour
il y a des boulangers qui ferment jolie
chaque jour il y a des boulangeries qui
meurent et ils pourront parvenir après
c'est terminé aujourd'hui on sait qu'il
y a une urgence incroyable là-dessus
est-ce que vous vous savez que si le
gouvernement fait quelque chose ou pas
parce que on a l'impression que là c'est
c'est voilà c'est c'est franchement
c'est un marasme total pour les les
boulangers notamment et pourquoi
pourquoi ça arrive pourquoi alors
pourquoi est-ce que certains ont leur
prix de l'électricité multiplié par 10
c'est parce qu'il y a une privatisation
de la vente de l'énergie à cause des
règles européennes et ça c'est pas
normal donc il faut absolument réformer
le marché européen qui a imposé la
privatisation c'est à dire que des
opérateurs sont venus sur ce créneau
même des opérateurs qui par exemple
total est venu sur ce créneau de rachat
et de vente d'énergie puis vous souvenez
les publicités bien sûr sur ma quitter
EDF et puis venez même les centres
Leclerc à un moment on fait de l'énergie
et puis même les par exemple rester sur
cet exemple les centres Leclerc le jour
où ça leur a pas rapporté suffisamment
ils ont quitté le marché et les gens se
sont retrouvés sans électricité et sans
opérateur énergéticien donc il y a eu
des prédateurs qui sont venus sur ce
marché dans l'achat et de la revente
d'énergie alors que c'est les Français
qui ont payé les centrales nucléaires
c'est les Français qui ont payé pendant
des années la production d'énergie il y
avait aucune raison d'accepter cette
privatisation donc il y a des solutions
en reprenant le contrôle national de la
production et de la vente de
l'électricité alors vous venez aussi
dans votre livre sur les moqueries ou
les attaques dont vous avez été victimes
même dans votre propre camp lors de la
campagne de 2007 vous dites on dit mais
qui va garder les enfants je n'avais pas
mesuré à ce moment-là le ressort profond
de jalousie de cette attaque lorsque
j'ai été candidate à la présidentielle
ce n'était pas anecdotique par
l'autruchement d'une violente
contestation de compétences le renvoie
aux tâches domestiques s'occuper des
enfants c'était la contestation d'une
intrusion dans un monde censé être
réservé aux hommes vous rappelez que sur
180 chefs d'État dans le monde il n'y a
qu'une quinzaine de femmes et c'est vrai
que vous étiez vous étiez pas loin c'est
vrai que c'est Nicolas Sarkozy vous
n'étiez pas loin Ségolène et est-ce que
vous avez senti une grande jalousie
quand un moment on a senti quand même
qu'il y avait une dynamique est-ce que
vous avez senti qu'il y en avait même
dans votre camp qui se disait
on a on a pas on n'a pas envie qu'elle
gagne
autour de mon adversaire ça faisait bloc
là émerger une femme oui il y a plein
d'hommes qui qui se dit mais non c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas sa place et
c'est vrai qu'il y a une première femme
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'était pas anecdotique
et malgré ses oppositions c'est c'est
c'est
dénigrement y compris dans mon propre
camp j'arrive quand même au second tour
de la présidente oui c'est pour ça que
on s'est quand même une
réussite et vous avez pensé à un moment
dirait un moment je vais je vais arrêter
je vais pas y aller
non parce que vous avez la
responsabilité après des gens qui vous
suivent vous avez cru croire à ce moment
vous êtes dit je vais gagner oui je
pense bien sûr
quelles sont vos relations avec eux
Nicolas Sarkozy
je le rencontre pas non j'arrête pas du
tout non mais c'était une belle campagne
c'était une très belle campagne
moi j'aime beaucoup Nicolas Sarkozy
aussi je vous aime beaucoup mais je suis
aussi
une belle campagne il y avait deux
incarnations exactement personnalisées
oui c'était pas un vote de barrage
non il y avait un vrai choix il y avait
un vrai choix c'est la dernière belle
élection je le pense vraiment il y avait
deux proposition parce que je dis parce
qu'après il y a eu François Hollande
face à Nicolas Sarkozy c'était c'était
plus contre Nicolas Sarkozy exactement
à chaque fois on a à chaque fois au
deuxième tour on a voté contre c'est
c'est la dernière élection où là il y
avait deux projets et on disait on vote
pas contre on vote exactement et les les
47% qui a fait
c'était de l'adhésion c'était voilà
c'était joli donc c'est vrai que c'était
c'est pour moi c'est la dernière grande
élection
est-ce qu'il y a certaines remarques
certains agissements qui vous ont
particulièrement marqué en politique
est-ce qu'il y a des des des hommes
voilà parce que c'est un milieu où il y
a énormément d'hommes est-ce qu'il y a
eu des comportements un peu lourdaux
beaucoup vraiment beaucoup sexiste
il y en a qui vous est resté en tête
une commission de d'enquête sur les
farines animales vous souvenez de ce
scandale
donc très rural et donc j'étais membre
du bureau de cette commission et il y a
effectivement un député qui dit mais ça
fera une vache folle au bureau et
personne n'a bougé
moi je me réjouis quand même de
l'évolution parce qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
même au sein du psy genre
je sais pas par exemple chez le requin
avait dit non mais vous allez pas
confier la France à Ségolène Royal c'est
comme confier un poids lourd qui
transporte de l'énergie nucléaire à
quelqu'un qui a pas le permis de
conduire par exemple
où il y avait toujours les ils avaient
inventé mais ça c'était plus du côté de
mon adversaire le musée elle fait des
bourdes dès que j'essaie quelque chose
elle fait des bourdes c'était c'était
malin en termes de communication parce
que c'était ils avaient conçu
bourde qui rime avec gourde donc c'était
une atteint une attaque à mon
intelligence au fond c'était une femme
est forcément idiote mais il voulait
vous faire perdre elle dit que moi je
pense que même dans votre compte
qui voulaient bien sûr moi je parlais
avec beaucoup de gens à l'époque qui
était
c'est ça c'est souvent dans le propre
camp aussi qu'on vous met le plus le
plus de de difficultés de peau de banane
les amis sont pire que les amis
exactement
bien sûr parce que j'étais une femme
avec les hommes se disaient
non c'est pas c'est pas sa place et donc
j'étais une intruse finalement j'ai osé
transgresser au fond un interdit du
droit à accéder aux responsabilités et
finalement ça ouvre aussi ouvert la voie
plein de femmes je pense que vous étiez
vous est-il la meilleure candidate en
2007 va jouer dans leur camp dans votre
camp je pense que c'est la meilleure
candidature en plus j'ai pas j'ai
personne
mais je pense qu'il est arrivé bien sûr
avec 60% des gens
pouvaient venir voter c'est important de
le rappeler non mais je dis c'est
important de le rappeler parce que
c'était c'était pas face à d'autocars
est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez ce
qu'il y en a des parfois on la nuit vous
rêvez que vous avez été élu où est-ce
que pour vous cesser ça reste un
traumatisme ou ça reste un beau souvenir
fils ça reste un beau souvenir pour vous
la campagne c'est magnifique parce que
c'est un c'est un dialogue avec le
peuple avec les gens avec les c'est
extraordinaire une campagne
présidentielle
bien sûr
de ce que je recommande d'ailleurs en
disant les gens sont tellement fatigués
vous voyez des ego et des et des
itinéraires personnels je ne sais pas
c'est l'histoire qui décidera c'est le
moment qui décidera moi je ne demande
rien je j'ai mon expérience politique
j'ai ma passion pour le pour le pays
on la démocratie participative pour
l'écologie c'est tout donc si vous
parlez de la brutalité dans la politique
vous dites la brutalité de ce monde
politique avec un exemple assez fou d'en
parler vous avez vu votre domicile
saccagé par deux fois j'ai subi saccage
son vol juste pour faire peur et sans
doute pour me décourager de la politique
car à ce moment-là en 2008 je suis
désigné comme la mieux placée pour
gagner la présidentielle quelques temps
plus tard le plan de mon domicile et de
ses accès sur à retrouver dans le coffre
de Bernard Squarcini ancien directeur du
renseignement c'est fou ça on vous a
fait plein vous voulez
les petits les petites affaires de ma
fille étaient alignés sur son lit comme
ça comme la mafia comme la mafia et et
pendant la campagne tous les ordinateurs
de toute mon équipe rapprochée ont été
volées la même nuit c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a eu des il y avait des barbouzes quoi
qui qui ont des spécialités qui sont
spécialistes des intrusions sans
effraction et qui font des procédures
des procédés des méthodes de de mafieux
quoi d'intimidation
j'ai rien dit parce que je me suis dit
je vais susciter
des réactions de dingue qui vont dire ah
ben on peut rentrer chez Ségolène Royal
en plus mon adresse avait été mise
partout ça après vous avez préféré
dans le livre c'est vrai que ça c'est
une histoire folle aussi c'est très fort
vous vous parlez aussi alors je vais pas
dévoiler tout le livre mais c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment très très fort tout
ce que dit Ségolène vous parlez aussi
parler énormément de fraternité et
d'amour vous allez aussi sur un sujet
inattendu parler de la Marseillaise pour
vous les paroles doivent être repensées
cet appel à l'amour est inscrit dans
notre devise républicaine la fraternité
beaucoup moins il est vrai dans les
paroles de notre hymne national qui
avait du sens à l'époque et pour lequel
de nombreux enseignants en s'adressant à
la ministre de l'Enseignement scolaire
que j'étais confiait leurs difficultés
d'expliquer et de faire aimer ses
paroles qui dans les temps présent
mériterait sans doute d'être repensé
sans tabou pour vous il faut repenser
avec cette team de la Marseillaise moi
que j'ai pour la première fois à gauche
d'ailleurs remis dans les meetings donc
c'est c'est un hymne révolutionnaire ce
qui avait un sens quand elle quand cette
team n'a été conçue on connaissait sans
doute les belles paroles de Louise
Michel la communarde révolutionnaire qui
dit tous les matins elle chantait la
Marseillaise dans sa classe et elle en
pleurait parce que c'était l'idée aux
armes citoyens le sens a pur c'était
contre les armées de l'étranger qui
voulaient venir en France écraser la
Révolution et aujourd'hui combien de
tellement souvent quand j'étais mise
enseignement scolaire j'entendais des
enseignants dire mais c'est compliqué
d'apprendre la Marseillaise parce qu'on
dit aux enfants
igorent-ils vos fils vont combattre le
sang à pur qui a pas besoin et même dans
le sport c'est difficile parfois pour
les sportifs comprennent pas le sens des
mots et quand on regarde et donc ça
mériterait d'être complété et quand on
regarde les paroles des hymnes des
autres pays c'est sur le progrès sur la
fraternité sur la fierté sur l'amitié
voyez c'est des choses qui qui
transporte
[Musique]
isoler les paroles si vous voulez le
sang a pur et gorgez vos fils vos
compagnes c'est c'est c'est assez
violent donc les enseignants dit mais on
apprend la non-violence aux enfants et
on n'arrive pas à leur expliquer ça bon
c'est ni urgent ni mais c'est dans le
lit qui change les choses mais ça serait
un beau une belle démarche peut-être
avec des enfants et des adolescents
d'ailleurs pour les sportifs de
réfléchir de repenser
ses paroles pour qu'on a un destin
commun vous avez regardé manuel Macron
hier
j'ai trouvé que qui répondait pas à la
détresse aujourd'hui du peuple français
que c'est une connerie là pourquoi tout
le monde tous les présidents voulu la
faire et tout le monde tous les
présidents ont dit que c'était
nécessaire de faire cette réforme ils
sont tous revenus en arrière et Emmanuel
Macron est le seul qui va au bout
le problème c'est pas de réformer pour
réformer c'est de faire de bonnes
réformes pensez que c'est pas une bonne
réforme pour les Français parce que on
est on est là pour la plupart contre ici
en plus mais est-ce que c'est vraiment
une mauvaise réforme pour les Français
parce que si on écoute le gouvernement
le gouvernement nous dit on est obligé
de la faire sinon sinon ils disent il y
a même manuel Macron il dit moi de toute
façon je suis élu encore jusqu'en 2027
donc si je voulais être aimé j'aurais
pas fait cette réforme franchement j'ai
pas besoin de la faire ça m'amène que
des que des que voilà que que des merdes
ils le dis c'est vrai donc voilà donc il
le fait dit c'est pour le bien des
Français est-ce que c'est vraiment pour
le bien des Français
pourquoi il le fait et qu'il ose pas
reculer c'est ça vous pensez que c'est
que ça bon il a dit au début du
quinquennat qui toucherait pas à l'âge
il le fait quand même il dit qu'il y a
besoin de financement c'est faux puisque
le système est équilibré comme l'a dit
donc c'est une réforme idéologique qu'on
lui a imposée au niveau européen on dit
au niveau européen et vous regardez il
faudra il faut il faut que la France
recule sur les services publics parce
que le modèle français n'est plus
conforme au libéralisme il faut tout
privatiser c'est plus efficace mais non
on est en France on a notre histoire on
a nos services publics et il y a aucune
raison qu'on en rabatte sur l'école sur
l'hôpital qui attendent des remises à
niveau sur la retraite sur la sécurité
sociale qui ont été construits par nos
parents nos grands-parents après la
guerre à un moment où la France avait
beaucoup moins de moyens qu'aujourd'hui
comment ça se fait qu'on nous dise
aujourd'hui qu'il y a plus d'argent
alors que ces acquis sociaux étaient
construits à la Libération à un moment
où la France n'avait plus rien et
d'autre part quand les Français voient
les profits les profits boursiers les
profits financiers qui explosent la
suppression de la peau de sur la grande
fortune financière totale qui en France
mais l'argent franchement on peut le
trouver quand même sur les les
profiteurs de crise notamment le secteur
de l'énergie le secteur de la banque le
CAC 40 franchement que de prendre deux
ans de vie aux gens surtout dans les
métiers les plus difficiles mais ce que
je crois c'est qu'il faut se poser juste
que c'est parce que c'est limite c'est
il veut pas il veut pas reculer il a dit
il a dit je l'ai dit je le fais c'est ça
et c'est ça tout simplement et c'est
très nocif alors c'est très mauvais
c'est le problème parce qu'on est entre
les mains d'un seul homme vous voyez il
y a une espèce de dérive autocratique on
sent on s'en fiche finalement de ce
qu'on pense je vais vous montrer une
vidéo je vais vous montrer une vidéo
parce qu'il y a une scène incroyable qui
s'est déroulée hier soir juste après la
locution du Président il est sorti dans
la rue et il était avec Brigitte
l'embrasse et il a fini par chanter un
champ pyrénéen avec des jeunes qu'il
avait interpellé regardez
qu'est-ce qu'on chante le refuge
avec vous alors
[Musique]
une petite image voilà alors c'est vrai
que ça fait énormément parler après bon
voilà il s'est fait puisque le groupe
avec le Californie
un autre fait d'actualité c'est vrai que
c'est mon ami mais vous pouvez tout dire
Marlène Schiappa
qui a fait la couverture de Playboy vous
êtes vous êtes prononcé là-dessus pour
vous il fallait pas la faire
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être ministre
elle serait pas ministre elle fait ce
qu'elle veut mais qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'être ministre être ministre c'est
c'est avoir un devoir d'exemplarité
quelque part
dans le fondateur et quand même un sale
type puisqu'il y avait il y a eu quand
même des problèmes de d'agression
sexuelle etc un journal qui fait quand
même du corps des femmes une marchandise
ça tout le monde est libre de le faire
de poser ou de d'acheter de le vendre
mais quand on est ministre quand on est
mère de famille en plus non on fait on
fait pas ça on choisit pas ça vous voyez
en plus un journal qui était en cours de
de faire faillite non il y a quand même
alors ils ont vendu plus de 100000
exemplaires c'est un carton total il
faut 30000 d'habitude
elle a choisi ce support pour justement
qui ne vraiment un retentissement sur
les causes qu'elle défend elle s'est dit
et c'est vrai qu'on en a jamais autant
parlé puisque dans l'interview elle
parle beaucoup de toutes les causes
qu'elle défend elle se dit en faisant ça
je vais quand même interpeller les gens
ils vont l'acheter et ils vont voir de
quoi je parle moi j'aime bien la
cohérence vous savez dans la vie j'aime
bien les valeurs cohérentes donc un
journal qui fait du corps des femmes une
marchandise une ministre qui défend soit
10 ans les droits des femmes et qui est
ministre en plus ne fait pas ça alors
justement que sa fille un jour pose nue
de pour vivre pose nu dans Playboy je
pense pas que vite ça pour ces enfants
je la défendrai toujours Ségolène vous
savez mais c'est vrai que voilà les
photos en plus elles sont pas très sont
pas très sexy ça va c'est trop sec ça va
ça passe
une ministre peut faire des photos comme
ça ça va c'est sobre
d'incohérences on sait plus où sont les
valeurs on sait plus où la hiérarchie de
ce qui est important de ce qu'il est
plus s'il y a plus s'il y a pas de
repères mais vous savez qu'on lui disait
tout le monde tout s'effondre on lui
disait la même chose à Marlène Schiappa
qui a été la première invitée politique
à venir ici et c'est elle a montré que
voilà les autres sont venus derrière et
plein de gens lui disaient aussi c'est
pas la place d'une ministre elle est
venue et c'est vrai que c'est très bien
passée et après plein de ministres ont
suivis et vous savez que tous les cons
et pratiquement tous les exactement tous
les candidats à la présidentielle sont
venus mais c'est vrai que voilà Marlène
Schiappa à quoi c'est bien
vous avez déjà rencontré oui elle m'a
demandé d'ailleurs elle est sympa très
sympa j'organise un déjeuner ça me fait
plaisir on a décidé on a décidé de
revenir avec vous aussi sur l'affaire 4
nains vous savez le député elle est FX
qui a été condamné pour violence
conjugale le 13 décembre dernier 4 mois
après on a appris qu'il réintégrer la
France insoumise trouver ça normal
ce que je trouve positif si vous voulez
c'est que le fait de donner de frapper
sa femme
soit devenu un fait de société et
susciter une sanction parce qu'il y a
pas si longtemps ça faisait rigoler ou
c'est de se passer à la trappe on dirait
c'est pas grave vous savez
ce fameux dicton là c'est frappe ta
femme si tu sais pas pourquoi
voilà on entendait ça avant donc je
préfère retenir ça en disant ben voilà
il y a une sanction bon après la
réintégration c'est il est paraît
intégré dans des responsabilités mais ce
que je ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que à ce moment là tous les
parlementaires qui ont voté par rapport
à la loi à ce moment doit être aussi
sanctionné oui il y en a un qui a été
près de la cocaïne un homme qui a été
pris pour pour agression sexuelle un
troisième qui est quand même eu
l'investiture de son parti voyez à ce
moment-là faut traiter tout le monde de
la même façon donc c'est quoi vos
rapports avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pas mauvais pas mauvais moi si je
voulais je trouve que il subit un excès
de critique je mets ce que je comprends
ça c'est la vie politique mais moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour les gens qui
sont engagés et qui travaillent qui ont
des choses à dire parfois avec excès
mais c'est aussi sa personnalité vous
avez voté pour qui vous ou à la
présidence pour lui pour lui bien sûr
vous l'avez dit oui j'ai dit penser
qu'il aurait fait un meilleur président
qui Emmanuel Macron mais je pense que
l'union de la gauche était absolument
nécessaire pour avoir comme on le disait
tout à l'heure au second tour quel que
soit son opinion ce que un vrai choix de
société est-ce que vous dites parce que
le vote
aujourd'hui dans un chaos complet en
France alors qu'il y a eu un vote
barrage qu'est-ce que vous aurez il
aurait dû avoir un rassemblement vous
dites aux gens qui disent que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est plus dangereux tous les
candidats pas son programme ses idées
ses crises de colère c'est c'est voilà
tout le monde dit que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
tout le monde dit que c'est moi
j'entendais tout le temps c'était
vraiment c'était je Mélenchon tout le
monde me dit si Mélenchon arrive au
pouvoir on quitte la France ceux qui
disent ça c'est pas des arguments
il faut qu'ils articulent un
argumentaire
situation dans laquelle on est et vous
voyez la catastrophe est-ce que vous
avez la vue la presse internationale
il y aurait une situation comme ça en
France je dirais des missions il y
aurait une presse internationale aussi
catastrophique
ne caricaturez pas entre il faut juger
les gens sur les actes
Macron n'est pas dangereux vous avez vu
la situation dans laquelle on est moi
j'ai écouté c'est une souffrance tous
les jours pour tous les Français quel
que soit leur opinion politique on
allume la télévision c'est une
souffrance bien sûr
les manifestants les manifestants
frappés les policiers blessés vous allez
commerçant désespéré l'explosion du prix
de l'énergie
est pas maîtrisée mais vous êtes comme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous êtes le désarme
vous êtes pour le désarmement de la
police vous y croyez elles sont son
histoire Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dans mon livre je suis pour une police
on ne dit pas aux policiers que le
peuple est un ennemi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon justement ce qu'il
dit il dit les polapolis est un ennemi
pour le peuple
très virulent sur dégager les places
publiques etc sur la base d'arrêter
illégaux il y a eu quand même un arrêté
qui a été pris par le préfet de police
qui interdit les rassemblements
nocturnes mais on est en République le
droit de droit de rassemblement
regarder les images même des femmes qui
sont frappées à terre non non mais ça on
l'a montré ici bien sûr mais Jean-Luc
Jean-Luc je vais vous dire une chose il
y aurait pas la réforme des retraites il
y aurait pas de manifestation donc il y
aurait pas de de besoin de de policier
bien sûr
ça part de la réforme des retraites
exactement une bonne gestion d'un pays
doit permettre de ne pas avoir de
manifestations c'est simple d'avoir la
paix sociale mais donc des exactions
pensez pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon se
réjouit du chaos absolument pas bah oui
vous êtes sûr absolument pas voulez-vous
se réjouir du chaos on le connaît un peu
voilà on le voit c'est ce qui prône
parfois voilà oui
mais comment est-ce que la République
vous seriez président de la République
ou Président on n'a pas les compétences
vous voyez ça à la télé vous dites non
non bien sûr cette réforme honnêtement
et pourquoi la gauche n'a pas supprimé
la réforme quand on est passé de 60 à 62
ans si on a intégré les facteurs de
pénibilité ce qui fait que tous les que
tous les métiers pénibles peuvent partir
à 60 ans et on a fait la durée de
cotisation et la première chose qu'a
fait manuel Macron en arrivant c'est de
supprimer les critères de pénibilité et
de supprimer l'indexation des retraites
sur l'inflation avant les retraites
augmentées automatiquement avec la
hausse des prix c'était très protecteur
ça ça a été supprimé soi-disant pour
sauvegarder le système de retrait et à
chaque fois il y a une nouvelle réforme
soi-disant pour sauvegarder le système
de retraite je vais vous dire
idéologique c'est pour faire peur aux
gens c'est pour que les gens aillent
vers les assurances privées les
retraites c'est 340 milliards d'euros
donc les assurances privées et les
bandes veulent mettre la main sur ce
pactole et si vous c'est comme pour
l'hôpital si l'hôpital public se dégrade
et ben l'Hôpital Privé va prendre la
clientèle et faire payer les gens et
dans cette révolte dans la rue ça va
au-delà des retraites c'est-à-dire que
les Français ont compris qu'il y avait
un déclin et que si on stoppait pas
cette réforme des retraites d'autres
choses à les basculer oui c'est une
façon de dire stop stop on veut plus que
ça décline on veut remonter la pente moi
je crois qu'on peut remonter la pente ça
l'objectif
la cruauté du monde je voudrais terminer
par cette phrase qui est magnifique qui
est une phrase très importante je trouve
si le climat avait été une banque il
aurait été sauvé depuis longtemps c'est
dans le livre de Ségolène Royal par le
client ça c'est très fort c'est elle dit
parce que je suis complètement d'accord
avec elle là dessus merci Ségolène Royal
d'avoir été avec nous refuser la cruauté
du monde le temps d'aimer est venu merci
à vous d'avoir été avec nous